SEASON.
IT'S BEEN THAT KIND OF YEAR AS
THE KRAKEN G.
IT'S 1-NOTHING TORONTO SNCHUCK
THERE'S MATTHEWS, THAT HIGH CURL
THAT OPENS UP THE PASSINGON SOUS
IT BY CAMPBELL
POPS BACK OUT, SOUCY HAS IT,
CAMPBELL SLIDING ACROSS ANÄRNKR
SCHWARTZ, IN, SHOOTS, CAMPBELL
GRUBAUER.
>> Gord: IN ALONE OFF TAVARES
AND SCORES!
JOHN TAVARES ON THE BREAK AND
LOOK AT THIS BREAKOUT PASS.
>> Gord: MATTHEWS' NEXT GOAL
WILL T T
KERFOOT WINDS IN.
NOW KASE HAS IT.
CENTRES IT.
SIMMONDS
RIELLY SHOOTS, BLOCKED BY
LARSSON. MATTHEWS WINS  MATTY
BENIERS IS
BUNTING, OVER TO BRODIE.
RINK WIDE FOR KASE.
BACK TO THE POINT FOR  AT 2-1.K
BACK
>> Gord: BOUNCES BACK TO
BACK TO THE FORECHECK.
LYUBUSHSH THE ZONE.THEWS GOT HI
60th POWERPLAY GOAL.
HE
DO
SCHWARTZ PLAYS THE PUCK AROUND
TO GET TO THE MIDDLE.
IT LOOKS ALMOST
THAT'S PICKED UP.
BUNTING FOR MARNER.
MATTHEWS IN, SCORES!
UP IN THE AIR, MARNER IN, SHOOT
SCORES!
MITCH MARNER, POWERPLAY GOAL AND
THE LEAFS ARE BACK IN FRONT!
WIN.
DONSKOI GETS FROZEN.
QUICKLY DEVELOPED, MATTHEWS  MA
AUSTON MATTHEWS BRING ON THE
>> Ray: GOAL 4